princess eugenie
says i do i usually victoria elena
i usually victoria hello take the
jack christopher stamp take the jack
christopher stone
to my wedded husband to my wedded
husband
the 28 year old royal tied the knot with
jack brooksbank at st
george's chapel at windsor castle the
same church where prince harry wed
meghan markle in may
sarah ferguson's daughter arrived to the
chapel in a black rolls-royce with her
dad
prince andrew who was by her side as she
made her way
up the stairs even stopping to help her
fix her dress
how cute is that the bride looks
stunning in an off-the-shoulder gown
with a lengthy train that showed off the
scars on her back from a surgery she had
at the age of 12 for scoliosis
an intentional choice that the princess
previously explained to itv
i think you can change the way beauty is
and you can show people your
scars and i think it's really special to
stand up for that
she paired the dress with a diamond and
emerald tiara from her grandma
queen elizabeth ii's personal collection
kate middleton
and prince william's two eldest kids
prince george and princess charlotte
were front and center for the i do's
george served as a page boy while
charlotte was one of eugenie's
bridesmaids
eugenie's sister beatrice had the
perfect passage in literature to honor
the couple on their special day
he smiled understandingly much
more than understandingly it was one of
those rare smiles
with the quality of eternal reassurance
in it
that you may come across four or five
times in life
an excerpt from the great gatsby it
understood you just as far as he wanted
to be understood
believed in you as you would like to
believe in yourself
and assured you that it had
precisely the impression of you that
at your best you hoped to convey
reverend andrew connor
explained that it was eugenie who
selected the passage
soon after she and jack
had first met that princess usually
read the great gatsby by
f scott fitzgerald
one particular passage in which jay
gatsby is described
reminded her immediately of jack
she decided that she wanted eventually
to let jack know how much those words
that brought him to mind and as if that
weren't enough
to give you all the feels
performed not one but two pieces during
the ceremony
but like any wedding it wasn't all
perfection
one of the page boys took a tumble on
the way into the chapel
right before the wind blew up one of the
guests dresses
exposing her underwear
and then there was this close-up shot of
one of the tiny bridesmaids picking her
nose
but all is well that ends well and from
the looks of it
eugenie got her happily ever after
[Music]
[Applause]
you